mic starts off this hour in Indianapolis
hey Mike Heidi thanks for taking my call
sure man what's up I'm trying to cobble
I've got a complicated question I'll try
to make it as short as I can my wife and
I have a Tony old friend that she met
through Big Brothers Big Sisters and
several years ago and the 20 year old
now has a one-year-old daughter and she
just asked us for $35 of diapers which
we gave her and we thought that was a
loan and then a couple weeks later she
asked us for $55 to give rental facility
because she has to move out of her
apartment
she's also posted pictures of vodka and
cigarettes on her Facebook page so she's
not making the right choices with her
money but she helped and my wife and I
don't know what to do okay well my rule
is real simple if someone is bold enough
to ask me for my money I'm bold enough
to attach requirements with the money
that are for their own good
and you know what's weird one of two
things will happen they will welcome the
help or they'll get mad that you're
interfering in their business and so my
help in this situation sounds like this
I mean I don't want to make her any
loans I do want to give her some money
this is a girl that didn't have a strong
upbringing she's struggling she's
already made a whole series of bad
choices is what you're describing to me
right right and so we've got to get her
on a path where she's making has better
thinking and therefore better choices
and how are we going to do that well you
know this is a whole lot more than just
am I going to give some by 35 bucks for
diapers the answer that's easy yes but
I'm going to do it in the form of a
grocery store gift card which most of
those do not allow alcohol and cigarette
purchases most of them limit them to
other types purchases or I'll go buy the
diapers and take them to them one of the
two that so that's a simple thing but
what's your what you're more than
anything pointing out is there's you've
realized that you're gay
being a drunk a drink meaning she's
gonna always have money problems until
she cracks some of these uh you know
some of these bad her bad thinking
that's leading the bad choices is that
right
okay and so what I would do is say hey
I'm going to do better than that what
I'm going to do is I'm going to help you
lay out your budget we're going to pay
for you to go through Financial Peace
University and you have to go to the
class and and then we're going to walk
with you and as we look at your budget
with you and see what you're spending
the money on as long as you stick to
what we are what we're telling you you
need to do for your own good then we'll
try to help you out occasionally with
stuff with a gift okay and and you know
that's assuming that's assuming you can
financially help somebody with a gift
but I mean fifty or a hundred bucks is a
big deal in this kid's life right but
giving it to her without any kind of
requirement that she think better and
that she live better is enabling it's
not helping but she was like two hours
away how do you verify what she's
feeling okay I didn't know that part I
thought I thought you said she was Big
Brother Big Sister so I figured she was
in your neighborhood but well I mean you
see how she asking by email by text my
tax actually okay all right well I mean
let's set her up with financial let's
set her up with Financial Peace
University and getting and then ask her
when she goes to class who the
coordinator is and that the coordinator
can coach her and can stay in contact
with you okay and verify and hold her
accountable and verify the good to see
the good thinking in the good decisions
something like that but I mean that it's
just a question it let me just tell you
helping people really helping them is a
lot more work than just throwing money
at them which actually doesn't help them
write it cuz you have to get it down in
their mess with them and walk with them
out of the mess and the mess is their
stinking thinking a zig Zigler you
say yeah and so yeah you just set up a
thing where somehow your your money is
influencing her life to be better not
just throwing money at because her
problem if she's got vodka and
cigarettes sitting there her problem is
not lack of money for diapers or
problems mismanagement and it might be
money but if you choose vodka and
cigarettes over your kids diapers that
means you need to be smacked silly
repeatedly you know I mean it's just
dumb who does that people do it every
day they do it every day that's who does
that and so you you know your job your
wife took this girl on as a mentor or if
you're not going to do that I'd suggest
you just cut her loose just cut her
loose no I'm not I help you cuz I'm not
gonna throw money at this situation if
you're not gonna do this stuff and you
could you could even say if she's got
some debt she's got some things okay
every time you pay off this much we'll
put some weather to help you pay it off
you can do matching you match towards
savings you could set up a $25 a month
thing that you're the custodian of for a
kid to go to college I mean you can do
all kinds of stuff that doesn't take a
lot of money but that is a lot of money
in her world and allows you to have
influence with her to force her to
change her thought patterns and her
habits and her behaviors but again
that's a lot of work I mean that's
loving somebody well and it's always
more work to love them oil
you